despite the massively multiplayer
ambitions hinted at in the games
earliest trailers open-world cooperative
shooters the division is not an MMO it's
realistic recreation of midtown
Manhattan will not be populated by human
players throughout like say dayz rather
you'll only find large groups of random
players in destiny styles social hub
areas that occupies all specific pockets
of the world map for the majority of the
game you'll simply partner with up to
three co-op buddies and battle AI
enemies across a series of discrete
story driven missions this is where my
hands on experience kicked off with New
York City rapidly descending into chaos
following a biological attack that saw
smallpox infected currency deliberately
introduced into circulation on Black
Friday after quickly customizing a
character selecting from a relatively
modest collection of pre-made faces and
hairstyles a chopper dropped me near the
Hudson piers enroute to the game's only
mandatory mission establish a command
center at the historic post office
across from Madison Square Garden once
activated this expansive regal building
becomes your home base for the rest of
the game providing a place to receive
missions purchase gear craft items and
interact with the game's characters it
also serves as a driving force behind
the game's narrative the base consists
of three wings medical tech and security
and each branch contains its own
storyline with dedicated missions that
eventually result in related unlocks and
upgrades after walking through the front
door and claiming the post office my
first real taste of the division's
combat came as my squad and I set out to
rescue the doctor who eventually
supplies the medical missions
interestingly the overall
moment-to-moment combat feels more like
an RPG imbued with shooter mechanics
rather than a shooter layered with RPG
trappings enemies for example absorb an
absurd amount of damage far more than
you'd expect based on the game's
grounded universe the controls feel
oddly unsure like as well in order to
throw a grenade for example you must
hold left on the d-pad select the
grenade type bring up the throwing art
by holding the left trigger and finally
throwing your explosive with the right
trigger once I grew accustomed to these
gameplay idiosyncrasies however I still
found plenty of things to love about the
divisions action the sticky cover and
health systems both work well but more
importantly enemy AI proves
savvy enough to demand strong squad
tactics from me and my teammates if we
didn't hold the line we would get
flanked and murdered but if we
successfully laid down suppressive fire
and force the opposition into a corner
we could flank them and save ourselves a
bloody firefight and when strategy
didn't quite pan out I was generally
able to rely on my character's special
skills to turn the tables
the divisions upgrade and progression
systems are extensive offering three
separate categories of both passive and
active abilities skills are most
definitely active allowing you to save
unleash an enemy seeking mine or break
out a riot shield and march into the
crossfire unscathed the loot system is
equally robust with dozens of
individually upgradeable pieces of gear
and a huge selection of weapon mods so
you can turn any firearm into your own
custom killing machine honestly the
options felt overwhelming but I expect
the game's RPG roots will shine through
and the entire experience will open up
after a few hours of upgrading and
customizing your character the one major
question that remained after my hands-on
time what will we find as we explore the
streets of New York City I was able to
engage in a few simple side quests but I
didn't have much time to explore will we
find encampments of survivors a diverse
collection of environments special loot
their rewards collectors guess we'll
have to wait for the divisions
long-awaited beta to launch later this
month
the third member of your team has
disavowed division affiliation the gene
will be Montrouge